fatal we're so used to it it has become
a fixture of American life down here too
short one minute you got three girls in
the jacuzzi
next minute somebody's in jail and you
have to bail them out that's what
happens down into short
the other thing that happens down at the
shore
chlamydia just a medically astounding
rate of chlamydia and it's heart
America's bail system sounds pretty
simple if you're charged with a crime
the court might ask for an amount of
money as bond and then return it to you
once you show up for trial and if you
have that money it's no big deal but if
you don't you can be in big trouble just
look at one example a man called
well he was arrested for driving with a
suspended license the court set bail at
$1,000 and he had a choice pay it all
await a trial in Rikers Island I don't
let me well and his wife take the story
from there a wooden bush Rikers on my
worst enemy
cuz it's rough it was hard and it's a
bomb I had to try to borrow money from
this person and this person and this
person should try to get him out he told
the judge I can't afford a thousand
dollar bail so he really didn't have a
choice but to plead guilty now whether
he was guilty or not the fact is a
non-violent offender spent time in
Rikers because he didn't have a thousand
dollars and this is a systemic problem
increasingly bail has become a way to
lock up the poor regardless of guilt
because we go Nick what was a family man
who posed no danger to society
whatsoever and he was stuck in Rikers
whereas millionaire Robert Durst who'd
been accused of murder in Texas had a
completely different experience at the
bail system I had been told by the
detective that you've been charged with
murder bail has been set at 250 thousand
dollars but was your intention when you
put up the $250,000 to run away Oh
goodbye $250,000 goodbye Jail I'm out
I'm out
that of course is an excerpt from robert
durst children's books
goodbye jail goodbye money
goodbye bail I killed them all but
goodbye jail of course of course
the problem is the frequency and cost of
bail have risen dramatically and it is
disproportionately hurting the poor in
fact in 2013 an analysis of New Jersey's
jail population found that nearly 40%
were being held solely because they
couldn't meet the terms of their bail
which is crazy jail is supposed to be
for dangerous criminals in 40% of a
group don't meet the basic criteria to
be there that should change your
perception of what that group is if 40%
of the Girl Scouts were grown men you
feel weird about buying cookies from
them so so what happens if you can't
make bail well much like a game of marry
kill with crosby Stills and Nash there
are a few terrible scenarios
option one you sit in jail and again if
you're poor as this defense attorney
explains that has immediate consequences
our clients work at jobs where if you're
absent you're fired
our clients live in shelters or in
transitional housing places where if
you're not there for the night your
place is gone so there are a lot of
different ways in which incarceration
even for a short period of time can
really destroy someone's life
exactly jail can do for your actual life
what being in a marching band can do for
your social life even if you're just in
for a little while it could destroy you
destroy that many defendants who can't
afford bail favor option number two
simply pleading guilty even if you're
not as a former public defender explains
you sit in jail because you can't afford
to pay your way to freedom and you're
often confronted with a deal that goes
like this plead guilty get out maintain
your innocence and go to trial stay in
and poor people are regularly choosing
to admit guilt just to get out of there
which isn't good the only time that's
appropriate is in a Catholic
confessional what what do you mean is
there anything else I don't know I
masturbated into a kiwi fruit is that
what you're they just let me leave I
have stuff to do
and the problem is if you do plead
guilty to a crime you didn't commit that
has its own downsides because
unfortunately on a job application next
to the question have you ever been
convicted of a crime check yes or no
most don't then leave four pages of
blank space to explain the social and
economic inequalities inherent in the
legal system and that brings us to your
final option commercial bail bondsmen
you know the people who make amazing ads
like these ruffies bail bonds has busted
out all over Middle Tennessee I ain't
going out like this
Oh my culprit bill balls cuz they got
calling me Miriam Jesus break bail bonds
for 10:00 to 9:00 to 302 that you're
locked up in the frame yes
well I will say it is a little weird
given that Jesus pretty memorably I
think was not bails out I mean he did
eventually escaped custody but it was a
real workaround of the system here here
is how that system works no bail
bondsmen promised the court to pay your
bail if you fail to show up for a trial
in exchange you pay them 10 to 15% of
the bail amount which they then keep
regardless of how your trial goes so if
your bail is $5,000 and you're found
innocent then you've basically just paid
a 750 dollar fee to a bondsman for doing
absolutely nothing wrong and paying $750
for absolutely nothing should be
reserved for one thing and one thing
only
six-month gym memberships that's it
you're not going to use it Gerald you're
gonna use the treadmill twice and that's
it this is learning to speak Korean all
over again - and if you don't show up
for your trial bail bondsman routinely
hire bounty hunters to track you down
and they have a frightening amount of
power in all but four states the
companies are legally allowed to take
almost any measure necessary to capture
a client including crossing state lines
and breaking into homes it's a dangerous
business for everyone involved with few
rules and little oversight oh they're
not kidding in 18 states anyone can
become a bounty hunter regardless of
education training or prior criminal
history becoming a bounty hunter is
basically a lot like becoming a social
media expert all it takes is want to get
bad enough and not caring about whether
strangers hate you or not
but but then the news that any idiot can
be a bounty hunter shouldn't really be
that surprising to you if you've ever
turned on A&E and stumbled across at
this I am along
Oh God when I say they know what I'm
saying
[Music]
the only way this guy will get away from
us is if it kills himself right now
and jumps into a pool of sharks okay
okay I hate to be a stickler over
chronology dawg
but how do you kill yourself and then
jump into a pool of sharks but that's
the kind of attention to detail job that
makes me worry about you operating as an
unregulated vigilante now that show was
so popular inspired pretty much every
other Bale business to pitch themselves
as a reality show just click around
online and you will find sizzle reels
for a veritable smorgasbord of similar
shows we're coming to get you the
natural high you got to think like I do
you like that and we get quicker than
that you want tough you want action meet
big Benning they call it a teddy bear
Denyce huntress it doesn't stop there
there's also Richard the screwdriver
Richard out the other Richard Alison the
greco-roman wrestler Caroline the one
who took up archery after watching The
Hunger Games and don't forget Jennifer
the arthritic alpaca in a bowler hats
actually you know what I now regret
making fun of that now that I'm seeing
the cast I get the appeal I want to see
those characters grow clearly these
shows are in a competitive marketplace
and the problem is when people try to
stick out ideas like this happen
so what do we do differently we don't
just gonna hurt without this each week
two new teams about waters
[Music]
go head-to-head welcome to the most
dangerous competition on television
belches okay first of all first of all
the most dangerous competition on
television is the Bachelorette those
women have left and they've lost lovers
are awarded but it's also a risk it's a
risk she's put herself on the line she's
there for the right reasons and second
it says something about how comfortable
we all are with how our bail system
works that a TV show where people with
guns hunt humans for sport seems
legitimate because we just think well
they're just doing their actual job and
when you give bounty hunters this kind
of power bad things happen
veteran Jean Travis says he was sitting
with his wife on his Bethpage front
porch next thing he knows his barn is
being searched and Travis has a stun gun
pointed at his back the intruders mark
Drummond and his wife Angela bounty
hunters who police say had the wrong
home clay was shot by one of the
bondsman
he was then transported to Ermac where
he died was a bounty hunter justified in
tasing a Midwest City homeowner last
Saturday was another justified in
shooting his dog police say the
videotape they took says no yeah the
video says no basic human decency says
no even a magic 8-ball having seen that
with saying holy I can't believe
you're even asking me
our current bail system makes no sense
and it does a lot of harm and the
frustrating thing is we've known this
for a long time just watch this TV news
special from 1964 yes the jails are
bursting at the seams a problem of great
concern to New York City Commissioner of
Correction and across remaining in jail
because you can't get bail is really
being punished before you're even found
guilty as far as I was concerned that
was not just that was destroying our
concept of justice that's right
this problem has been obvious since it
was considered okay to wear a
wastebasket on your head
look here's here's the good news there
is a better way and it's already in use
in our federal courts and in Washington
DC judges in Washington are allowed to
set money bail only if the defendant can
afford it the results have been far
fewer people spending time behind bars
we are the only city in America where
tonight at our Jail there is not a
single man or woman who is sitting
because they don't have the money to
meet their money back and it's a
testament it's a testament to the state
of our justice system that that
qualifies as bragging because that
should be the norm
he's like a bus driver showing up at
school saying 23 kids picked up 23 kids
dropped off I pitched a perfect game
pretrial services works like this after
you're arrested specialists assess if
you if you're dangerous or a flight risk
if a judge decides that you're not you
can go home and they may monitor you
with things like drug tests or ankle
monitors they even call you to remind
you of your court date it's a system
built on interviews pre-arranged
appearances and trusts much like
Scientology marriages only in this case
much more effective and pretrial service
programs have succeeded around the
country in places ranging from Oregon to
Florida and it is a truly frightening
state of affairs when Florida is a model
for progressive change it shouldn't be a
judicial example for anything did you
know by the way that under Florida law
if you possess all the 5 grams of meth
you can marry it that's a fact that's a
legal fact that's an actual photo that
ran in a newspapers wedding section in
Florida and yet and yet even counties in
Florida recognized our money bail system
is broken and not only is pretrial
services better it's cheaper a recent
assessment of one system showed it
costing only 1/10 as much as keeping
someone locked up which makes sense
because
calling someone to check in costs
virtually nothing this message brought
you by your mother your mother
she brought you into this world and we
got to your king bollocks once in a
while so if pretrial services are fair
up better and cheaper why aren't we all
using it or maybe because thanks to
reality shows we think that this is what
justice looks like we're gonna hunt this
gun down bad dog so so maybe we just
need a new kind of reality show to get
us used to the alternative you want up
you want action meet Steve Carr
he's one of the most respected pretrial
services caseworkers in the United
States so let's see okay it looks like
you were ticketed with public urination
no priors seems like a one-off sort of
thing can we count on you to be back
here in six weeks for your trial of
course great we're done here no this is
a routine thing statistically he's
virtually guaranteed to turn oh we're
done here
we're done here Steve by hand grenade
to the crack team of legal enforcers
meet Deborah hello this is Debra from
pretrial services I'm just calling to
remind you about your upcoming court
date this Thursday well you're welcome
I feel like it I can't you know
back to work and then there's Brett so
all these are risk assessments this is
all computerized but you know I keep a
yeah a hard copy just in case that's why
they call him the Annihilator
and finally Gerald the guy in charge of
urine tests clear if there's something
in there that's illegal
I will sniff it out so that's what I do
I'm a piss sniffer
we got one because this fall we'll be
bringing you all the thrills and
excitement of pretrial supervision if
this elite team brings people to justice
well we don't bring them to justice it's
more like we make arrangements for them
to bring themselves to justice ignore
that this show is full of high-stakes
drama pray I don't get you for Secret
Santa this year
Debra and interoffice romance gerald is
a blood
uh-huh yeah she wants me and if it were
to follow their cats I would hit that I
would knock the bottom out most
we take you closer to the action
[Music]
pretrial services coming this fall to
A&E it's cast effective mother
[Applause]
you